and once we win the house  do we have a better Speaker of the House  than MTG  [Applause]  that's amazing courage  are we gonna need her as Speaker of the  House to take it to the Democrats  [Applause]  all right let's let's let's remember  something here folks this is an  individual Marjorie Taylor green who  before being elected to the House of  Representatives in 2020 had never held  elected office in her life okay  she is a first-time first-term  politician that hasn't even served a  full term yet  that doesn't even have any committee  assignments and hasn't for over a year  and Steve Bannon is out there saying she  should be the Speaker of the House of  Representatives  because nothing matters anymore at this  point